buonasera a tutti
l'antartide immaginate una distesa
bianca piatta immobile è infinita
davanti intorno a voi c'è solo la linea
dell'orizzonte per 360 gradi da lì parte
il cielo è il cielo più blu che potete
immaginare non c'è inquinamento non c'è
niente ma niente di niente di niente
niente che si muova non ci sono le
nuvole
nemmeno gli uccelli in volo non ci sono
nemmeno gli odori tutto è congelato
anche il tempo questo e l'antartide
ma perché andiamo in antartide per la
ricerca si sa per esempio che la ricerca
climatica importante per il nostro
futuro sul pianeta
no chi di voi è già andata in antartide
alzate la mano per favore
benissimo
questo è un twin otter e l'aereo elica
che ci porta alla base concordia in
antartide la ricerca è mondiale quasi
tutti i paesi partecipano ai progetti
concordia infatti è una base di ricerca
internazionale si trova molto lontano
dalla costa è un posto completamente
isolato è in cima alla calotta polare a
3.270 metri di altitudine e sono 3.270
metri di stratificazione di ghiaccio è
una stratificazione che si è formata in
800.000 anni
siamo nel secondo millennio
a noi sembra tanto ma 800.000 anni
riusciamo a immaginare quanti sono di
fatto per studiare l'atmosfera delle ere
passate abbiamo perforato ed estratto
questo ghiaccio di 800 mila anni fa a
concordia fa molto freddo la temperatura
media in estate di meno 40 gradi
centigradi in inverno arriva fino almeno
80 guardate questa è la foto della
centralina meteo di qualche giorno fa e
questi
sono gli stivali della dotazione a
quelle temperature è molto importante
essere isolati dal suolo
poi noi indossiamo una serie di strati
di tessuto tecnico e pine e alla fine
c'è la tuta tutte le nazioni hanno una
tuta di un colore diverso
siamo come le squadre di calcio i
francesi per esempio hanno una tuta blu
e calda e comoda e anche molto ampia ma
soprattutto a un cappuccio con due
alettoni laterali che si agganciano sul
naso eccola sembrano usciti da guerre
stellari non so però vi assicuro che
questo cappuccio ci permette di stare
fuori fino a 8 ore consecutive anche se
c'è vento la tutta italiana invece è
rossa è molto più attillata di quella
francese e ha un buon taglio molto più
fashion
però non va agli alettoni sul cappuccio
così quando c'è vento
io mi devo mettere il paracollo poi mi
devo mettere il cappello e soprattutto
la mascherina modificata vedete una
pelliccia incollata in modo che io non
mi contro il naso bella poi ci sono vari
strati di guanti e alla fine le muffole
che chiaramente sono comodissime quando
devi evitare una vite sottilissima su
uno strumento prima di salire sull'aereo
quando diamo in antartide la prima volta
ci fanno vedere le immagini di sicurezza
eccole qua sono le immagini di tutti ma
proprio tutti gli incidenti che sono
capitati in antartide
in effetti però i rischi sono molti si
può avere un incidente aereo di
elicottero
ci può essere un incendio alla base si
può cadere in un crepaccio o si può
rimanere bloccati nel ghiaccio con un
mezzo in panne e in tutti questi casi
anche se si sopravvive all'incidente poi
si può morire assiderati ma si può anche
essere attaccate da una foca sì oppure
ci si può perdere nel white out
il white house è una delle condizioni
più pericolose letteralmente significa
bianco fuori arriva all'improvviso sulla
distesa bianca
sale la copertura nuvolosa bianca la
linea dell'orizzonte sparisce non c'è
più distinzione tra cielo e terra
poi arriva la nebbia che inghiotte le
distanze
e tutto lo spazio diventa bianco tutte
le direzioni sono uguali se non hai
navigatore addosso non sa più da che
parte andare
è come camminare in una nuvola di bianco
indistinto che puoi perdere e quindi
come morire assiderato ho visto il
whiteout la prima volta che sono andate
in antartide
stavamo risalendo la calotta polare per
arrivare a concordia la base allora era
in costruzione
io mi doveva occupare di un analisi
energetica degli impianti
con me c'erano solo compagni veterani
loro erano alla loro terza o quarta
missione in antartide
a un certo punto il pilota ci disse che
dovevamo fare uno scalo intermedio il
tempo stava peggiorando e noi avevamo
bisogno di altro carburante fuori
c'erano 45 gradi sotto zero quando siamo
atterrati era meet point un deposito di
carburante in mezzo al niente
i miei colleghi mi dissero copriti bene
che fuori fa freddo non è come sulla
costa
e poi hanno aperto il portellone 45
gradi sotto zero
non ti danno il tempo di pensare che
freddo 45 gradi sotto zero
ti arrivano addosso come un animale
aggressivo che ti vuole sbranare sono
rimasta completamente senza fiato
siamo scesi dall'aereo fuori non si
vedeva niente era tutto bianco sopra
sotto intorno i miei colleghi mi dissero
facciamo due passi davvero ci sciogliamo
un po le gambe ci sciogliamo le gambe
in queste condizioni però loro erano
esperti
io neofita li seguì avevo veramente
paura loro camminavano con passi
abbastanza decisi si capiva che erano
esperti
io no a ogni passo mi giravo volevo
controllare che l'aereo si vedesse
ancora e poi barcollavo sì me lo avevano
spiegato che nel white ata normale
perché anche le ombre spariscono e così
non riesce più a distinguere e dossi
dalle buche
però quando ti ci trovi loro niente
continuavano come se niente fosse
a un certo punto
per fortuna uno di loro si volta mi
osserva e torna verso di me mi toglie la
mascherina scoppia a ridere
la linea dell'orizzonte radi tissima
firma e toth era sparito
e certo era solo nella mia testa a
quelle temperature
tutto si congela all'istante anche il
respiro e il respiro aveva formato un
velo di ghiaccio sulla mia maschera ma
talmente l'istante che non me ne ero
accorta sono stata molte altre volte in
antartide
mi sono occupata dell'organizzazione
della missione e del coordinamento del
gruppo sono stata a capo della logistica
e capo di due spedizioni alla base
concordia
eppure l'antartide non ha mai smesso di
sorprendermi non solo perché lì è tutto
strano è come vivere su un altro pianeta
e non solo perché il cellulare non
prende nessuno ti può raggiungere i
soldi non servono a niente
non solo perché lì tutto si congela
all'istante
anche il respiro frigorifero per esempio
ti serve per riscaldare il cibo e non
solo perché lì il giorno uguale alla
notte la notte uguale al giorno ma
soprattutto perché tutta la nostra
esperienza è tutta la nostra conoscenza
sono continuamente travolti da una
valanga di imprevisti in antartide non
c'è nessuna certezza non c'è niente di
niente su cui puoi fare affidamento alla
fine ti arrendi però a quel punto
capisci meglio il rapporto che abbiamo
con la conoscenza la conoscenza è
fondamentale perché perché lo strumento
che ci guida come navigatore in
antartide non ti puoi improvvisare senza
la conoscenza si rischia davvero di
morire però proprio perché è lo
strumento che ci guida la conoscenza è
anche il nostro limite è un sistema che
si basa sul riconoscimento e se qualcosa
è nuovo non lo posso riconoscere
così posso perdere l'occasione di
pensare in modo diverso dal solito o di
fare qualcosa di creativo l'antartide ci
travolge con un incertezza permanente e
ci fa vedere il legame tra la creatività
e la resilienza la resilienza questa
incredibile capacità che abbiamo di
trasformare le situazioni anche più
critiche in positivo credo che una
valanga di imprevisti ci possa far
capire che è molto più interessante
sentirci contemporaneamente degli adulti
che la sanno lunga
e anche dei bambini che si sorprendono
continuamente perché non sanno ancora
nulla e forse è anche per questo che ci
piace viaggiare per farci sorprendere da
delle esperienze nuove che ci facciano
cambiare la nostra prospettiva
io vi ringrazio di aver condiviso questa
pillola di antartide con me e vi mando i
saluti dei miei compagni di spedizione